Una de las primeras veces que trajeron a un estadounidense a Japón
para que dirigiera un equipo de béisbol japonés profesional,
Bobby Valentine, en 1995,
se encargó de un equipo muy mediocre,
lo llevó a que finalizara en segundo lugar,
y lo despidieron instantáneamente.
¿Por qué?
"Bueno," dijo el portavoz del equipo,
"a causa de su insistencia en ganar".
(Risas)
El Japón oficial puede parecerse mucho a ese punto
que supuestamente duró dos horas y 12 minutos,
y jugar para no perder
puede quitar la imaginación, la audacia y el placer de todo.
Al mismo tiempo, jugar al pimpón en Japón
me recuerda por qué los coros se divierten mucho más que los solistas.
En un coro, su único trabajo es cantar su parte perfectamente,
llegar a sus notas con emoción,
y así poder ayudar a crear una magnífica armonía
que es mucho más poderosa que la suma de sus partes.
Sí, cada coro necesita un director de orquesta,
pero creo que un coro los libera del simple sentido de un niño de uno u otro.
Se llega a comprender que lo contrario de ganar no es perder,
es negarse a ver la situación en su conjunto.
Conforme pasa mi vida,
me alarma mucho que acontecimientos
tarden tantos años en evaluarse adecuadamente.
Un día, perdí todo lo que poseía,
absolutamente todo, en un incendio.
Pero con el tiempo, llegué a entender que fue esa pérdida aparente
lo que me permitió vivir en la Tierra más tranquilamente,
escribir sin notas,
y mudarme a Japón
donde hay ese centro deportivo interior conocido como la mesa de pimpón.
Por el contrario, una vez encontré por accidente el trabajo perfecto,
y llegué a entender que esa felicidad aparente
puede obstaculizar la verdadera alegría
incluso más que la tristeza.
Jugar dobles en Japón me libera de toda mi ansiedad,
y al final de una tarde,
noto que todos salen en un estado de deleite más o menos parecido.
Todas las tardes me recuerdan
que no salir adelante no es lo mismo que quedarse atrás
que no estar lleno de vida no equivale a estar muerto.
He llegado a comprender por qué
se dice que las universidades chinas ofrecen diplomas en pimpón,
y por qué investigadores han afirmado que el pimpón
puede ayudar un poquito con trastornos mentales leves
e incluso con el autismo.
Pero cuando vea las Olimpiadas de 2020 en Tokio,
estaré completamente consciente
de que no será posible diferenciar los ganadores de los perdedores
durante mucho tiempo.
¿Recuerdan ese punto que mencioné
que supuestamente duró dos horas y 12 minutos?
Uno de los jugadores de ese partido terminó, seis años más tarde,
en los campos de concentración de Auschwitz y Dachau.
Pero salió con vida.
¿Por qué?
Sencillamente porque un guardia en la cámara de gas
lo reconoció de sus días como jugador de pimpón.
¿Había ganado ese épico partido?
Apenas importaba.
Como recuerdan, mucha gente había salido
antes de que se terminara el primer punto.
Lo único que le salvó la vida
fue el hecho de que había participado.
La mejor manera de ganar cualquier partido,
me dice Japón cada dos tardes,
es nunca, nunca pensar en el marcador.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)